[Applaudissements]
vertige tous les jours depuis six mois
j'ai des vertiges et une batterie
d'examens effet c'est la thyroïde qu'est
ce que je vais te retirer la thyroïde
monsieur voilà ça vient de là on a
étudié donc ils seront opérés passe sur
le billard le retard là la thyroïde il
revient six mois après vous docteur j'ai
des vertiges terrible tous les jours des
vertiges et des vertus ça me pourrit la
vie rebattrait d'examen les faits
monsieur pour retirer la rate
quels rapports la thyroïde daratt
c'était lié monsieur voilà il passe sur
le billard le retire à la rate
il revient six mois après le docteur
divertit et jetée rive tous les jours
des vertiges 10 et les testicules lavaud
déséquilibre car les testicules
il se présentait aux collatéraux y
dollar at oui oui c'est votre vie en
dépend monsieur faut passer sur le
billard
il se fait opérer et on les retire les
testicules il revient six mois après
fait lecteurs j'ai des vertiges horrible
plus que jamais c'est horrible et oui
j'ai reçu votre bilan je suis désolé de
vous le dire brutalement mais il vous
reste trente jours à vivre et le typhon
roke 30 jours mais je vais bien les
livres il sent de là il va chez un
chausseur elle et je voudrais 30 paires
de chaussures ils achètent plus grands
couturiers et dit mettez moi 30 costumes
un par jour je vais des livres très bien
ces 30 jours il m'est témoin 38 mise et
le dj vous faites du combien de tours de
cou il fait je fais des trente huit mecs
le net sur wimbée 38
il musulin fait non pardon monsieur vous
faites du 40 il dit écoutez les gentils
c'est être en tant que maire du 38 alors
donnez moi du 38 10 lycées comme vous
voulez mais si vous êtes trop serré
après qu'est ce qui va se passer
vous allez avoir des vertiges terrible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
margot toile lé mois préc éminemment
spectacle j'aime beaucoup avec jean
claude van damme à dire maintenant
souvent et si tu as quelque chose dans
les mains et que tu vois pas ce que
c'est c'est que c'était lunettes
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un mec acheter un pavillon
il a une femme deux enfants tout se
passe bien il dit bon avion comme ça
chauffe dans les pavillons
il va acheter un chien il achète un
doberman le doberman la première nuit ce
réveil tu la femme non ah ouais la mort
et là tu le perds les comme en fou et
tout le monde vient faire les cons
damnés ross sauf qu'en face de la maison
il ya plein de mecs qui sont là et le
petit vent voire leçon perdu mais papa
maman il connaissait tous ces hommes dit
non ils sont venus acheter le chien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avali c'est un vieux papy rentrer dans
la chambre de son petit fils y voit son
petit fils
affalé dans son lit en train de jouer
aux jeux vidéo il dit mais qu'est ce que
tu fous sans déconner c'est ça la
jeunesse s'est passé des heures à jouer
sur les conneries et moi quand j'étais
jeune je faisais quoi j'étais au moulin
rouge tous les soirs j'ai dansé avec des
filles je pilotais des filles je dansais
je monte sur la table ivre mort je
buvais des coups je pissais sur la table
et je partais sans payer ça c'est elle
la vraie jeunesse et le ghana il un peu
interloqués par les secours de son grand
père le grand père il repasse quinze
jours après il rentre dans la chambre et
la voyez il voit son gamin tuméfié un
oeil au beurre noir
le bras dans le plâtre la gueule des
fêtes idée mais sans déconner qu'est ce
que t'as foutu
il n'avait pas pu gérer exactement ce
que tu m'as dit de faire je suis allé au
moulin rouge
j'ai bu des coups j'ai peloter les
filles j'ai pas payer l'addition je suis
monté sur la table chez pisser sur la
table me suis barré sans payer comme toi
t attends attends attends mais c'était
avec qui vont taper ça il y bien j'étais
avec des amis je t'ai que des amis
pourquoi tu t'es qui toi s'en vont
perdre y un mois chez tech les allemands
[Applaudissements]
libéré cucs et un imam un rabbin un
prêtre en train de boire un verre
tranquille c'est ça la france le mélange
est brave et ridicule comment vous
faites vous quand vous faites la quête
au fait qu'est ce qui va dans votre
poche et qu'est-ce qui va chez dieu par
le chrétien aider nous on a un mur qui
rentrait d'un mètre on tape contre le
mur d'argent tout ce qui est derrière le
xiii c'est pour dieu et tout ce qui est
avant le 13 c'est pour nous d'accord
c'est vous les musulmans comment fait il
dit nous on a un saut au jette sur ce
qui va dans le seau c'est pour dieu tout
ce qui va à côté c'est pour nous dire
vous les rabbins ou fait et dit non
j'attends tout ce qu'il est en hausse et
pour dieu
[Applaudissements]
c'est un mec qui rentre chez lui il est
hyper fatigué l'on peut plus rendu
travailler l'antenne qui doit dans sa
tête qui lui dit abandonne ton travail
vite on compte vends ta voiture va monte
carlo et met tout sur le neuf
lorsqu'à possible en train d'halluciner
proposer si la personne qui parle
d'internet comme ça c'est impossible et
où il y va dans sa cuisine commence à
faire à manger lavoie revient abandonne
ton travail
vends ta voiture vip confronte va à
monte carlo et met tout sur le neuf
c'est pas la possibilité ce qui m'arrive
la vienne autre question qui parle dans
ma tête qu'est-ce qui va continuer ma
tei travail coaching comme ça pendant
deux semaines en deux semaines la voie
revient et tour à jouer et rentrer chez
lui
la voix qui revient dans sa tête
abandonne ton travail vite on compte
vingt voitures va monte carlo et met
tout sur le neuf lie craque
le lendemain il abandonne son travail et
vend sa voiture y vend sa maison est
vide son compte il va à monte carlo et
rentre dans le casino quand ils rentrent
d'un casino la voix lui dit mais tout
sur le neuf
il arrive devant la table la rouille à
roulettes il prend tout son argent il
met tout sur le neuf la roulette est
paraître tourne et tourne et tourne la
biais s'arrête pas elle s'arrête sur le
13 elle a la voix fait est maire
il
ben moi j'ai celle des mecs qui savent à
7 heures le matin 7 juillet arrivée et
dit tiens c'est drôle si on regarde son
billet de train ni les sièges 77 voiture
cette [ __ ] il ouvre son son agenda il
a rendez-vous dans 7e arrondissement au
7 de la rue 7e étage [ __ ] dirait si
c'est pas un signe
il compte l'argent qu'il a sur lui il a
exactement en vidant les pièces devenait
il à 777 euros sur lui
[ __ ] ils font ce champ de courses il
attend la 7e course et met tout sur le
cheval numéro 7
eh ben il est arrivé 7e là il à sa femme
qui est enceinte elle me coûte chérie je
veux manger du poisson mais je veux pas
le poisson de leader je veux aller
pêcher le poisson il y va le mec n'a
jamais été à la pêche
ils rentrent à qui voit mais dit [ __ ]
to thé glacé il fait un trou il met sa
canne à pêche et là elle entend y a pas
de poisson ici une jambe au dieu merci
il va elle fait un deuxième trou il met
sa canne à pêche on vous a dit qu'un pas
de poisson ici c'est mon dieu merci
le tennis est pas dieu c'est le
directeur de la patinoire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]